[Musique]
souviens-toi de la voix dans ta
tête celle qui a dit se faufiler
qu'est-ce qu'un arrêt c'est une aventure il
n'y a pas d'arrêt
ici c'est d'où elle vient ainsi a
commencé la légende de peter le garçon
qui ne
grandirait pas
je suis barbe noire
[  Musique]
bonjour, qu'est-ce qui lui est arrivé,
il a perdu son meilleur ami et ses chiffres ont
commencé à augmenter et à
quoi cela ressemble-t-il et plus vous vous sentez vieux,
plus ça va vite, je vais tous vous aider à
vous sentir à nouveau jeune
tous les enfants grandissent
mais certains s'échappent
tu sais croire qu'à partir d'ici
le monde n'a pas de fin
ça continue encore et encore
envie de voler
[Musique]
toi